Is your dog friendly or just ugly?
Very friendly.
But he's not a dog.
I am going to sue you for every last- ah!
Good dog.
Tonight's winning number was approximately
six.
Don't most pets eat at home and poop outside
like college students?
Nibbler prefers his litter box. It contains
precious sand with essential minerals from
his home world. Plus, it's got nose-numbing
crystals.
So that's why you never clean it.
Uh, right.
And speaking of changing the subject, who
wants to see the new alien language movie by
Bax Glygglif?
I heard it's brilliant.
Oh, sorry. I don't do subtitles.
When I go to the movies, I don't want to have
to look up from my phone.
I'd like to see the film, Leela!
Nibbler!
You can talk!
You always forget I can talk.
Nibbler! You can talk!